so about this time last year
my team has had built we had built over
several years our rails app on the rails
asset pipeline and so you can imagine
for an application that's been around
for several years there's a lot of
legacy code that's built up so we had a
heavy use of global variables in our
JavaScript JavaScript snippets and our
Ruby templates tons of rails asset gems
and we weren't quite sure how this would
all fit together as we were moving
forward our development experience and
started to decline somewhat it would
take a long time for the page to refresh
we were frustrated that our use of
source Maps was somewhat limited and so
we made this decision let's switch over
to web pack we had some vague idea that
things would be better turns out for us
the task was not so easy so we had all
these assumptions that we had made and
and part of the challenge was how do we
get web pack to work with our legacy
decisions that we had made over time but
we had a lot to learn about web pack
itself and so we had a lot of
assumptions coming from our experience
with the rails asset pipeline that we
assumed would just work in web pack and
the problem with having a sprockets or
rails asset pipeline mindset when using
webpack it's like a little bit like
trying to fit a square peg into a round
hole so we made our job hard on
ourselves and now that we've made the
switch we're better informed about how
web pack works about what we do
differently if we were to do it again
and so this is the talk now that I would
have liked to have seen before I started
and hopefully regardless of whether
you're considering upgrading a legacy
app or starting a greenfield project on
web pack I hope that we can pull out
some lessons for everybody so the main
structure of this talk we're going to
talk about three general scenarios that
fall under the umbrella of packaging
assets for the browser we'll talk about
six problems that our team encountered
in making the switch to web pack
and we'll come away with seven general
lessons survival tips that I think will
be applicable to anyone considering this
change but first let's make sure that
we're all on the same page about
sprockets and webpack they're meant
generally to solve the same problem
which is packaging assets for the
browser and by assets
I mean JavaScript style sheets web fonts
images and it's important to understand
that they go about trying to solve this
problem in fundament and fundamentally
different ways and one of those key
differences is how they group files
together into one or fewer that are
served to the browser and so in
sprockets
when it puts your JavaScript files
together it does file concatenation and
when that javascript is evaluated in the
browser its evaluated in the global
scope web pack is a static module
bundler
that basically means each one of your
files is converted to a module that has
its own scope in the browser and just
this key difference has a lot of
implications for the kinds of decisions
you can make and it took us a while to
actually let this difference sink in
we had a vague sense when we made the
switch that there be a lot of
improvements and now a year later I'm
really happy to say that that bet is
paid off we have better development
tools I feel in the webpack environment
along side rails I feel that webpack is
a better strategy for managing
dependencies
there's a huge ecosystem bolstered by
the large JavaScript community that we
can more easily take advantage of we can
write our code in es6 although I should
say sprockets 4 which is still in beta
would allow you to do this as well and
we can take advantage of a lot of new
features that are not presidents brought
in sprockets or the rails asset pipeline
one of which is dynamic code splitting
which I'll get to a little later
so what despite all these great ideas
and features and improvements you spend
a little time researching webpack on the
web and you'll come across quite a bit
of emotion some people hate web pack
some folks passionately hate web pack
sometimes getting things to work is a
little bit like trial and error often
because we don't necessarily understand
everything that's going on some folks
feel that web pack is over engineered
and that all this work it might take to
get this configuration right is really
not of benefit to your team there's even
a website devoted to those WTF moments
that folks have when trying to get web
pack set up and to be honest I've had a
few of those moments myself some of
which you'll see today although one of
the key decision points for us are to
encourage us to make the switch was that
rails announced official web pack
support through the web Packer Jam last
year and so what web Packer basically
does is try to bring rails conventions
this rails is omakase approach
convention over configuration these
ideas to web pack which generally
doesn't make any decisions for you it's
fairly unup enya nated and that's goes
slightly against what we typically think
of as rails philosophy so this won't be
a web pack tutorial I will though
recommend these three resources which
really helped B understand and get up
and running with web pack this survived
Jay s web pack book by Juho The Learning
Academy from Sean Larkin who really is
the tireless
person for webpack itself and webpack
from nothing by david copeland so let's
get into these survival scenarios things
that we encountered as we made this
switch so we had to address some
challenges with organizing our code with
taming the dependencies that we were
moving over to web pack and predictable
caching so jumping into this first
category for one of the first questions
we have once we get web pack up and
running in rails environment is how do
we organize our directory structure and
taking a step back to the rails asset
pipeline the default layout typically
for your JavaScript would be to place
everything in your app assets Java
scripts directory some special files in
there would be configured to be
precompiled to be output into the public
directory when you want to serve these
assets in production you might need to
use some rails configuration to say hey
in addition to application j/s I want
these other files to be bundled up as
well
let's take a look how the directory
structure should look like when you
integrate with web Packer so taking this
a source code that we had in the rails
asset pipeline you can move it over to
the app JavaScript directory when you
get web pack setup
a really nice feature of this separate
layout is that you can run sprockets and
web pack side by side so what we
actually did was move these files over
one by one to get things working and
you'll notice that there's a special
directory in under JavaScript called
packs that's just a term that web Packer
created but the generic term that it
really refers to when web pack is called
entry and these would sort of correspond
to those bundles that will then be
output into the corresponding public
directory and in web pack parlance this
is called output and really there's no
extra configuration that needs to happen
anything that goes into the packs
directly directory specifically
JavaScript files will be pre compiled so
to speak into the public directory
unfortunately a lot of folks get this
wrong
I paid quite a close attention a lot of
tension to the web Packer issues and a
lot of folks essentially report problems
not with web Packer but that ultimately
go down to misunderstanding how to
organize their directory structure see
instead of laying out their files this
way they make it look a little bit more
like what we had in sprockets they put
everything in the packs directory or
this tends to be a common problem that's
kind of what we used to do in the rails
asset pipeline so it must work in web
Packer right well this actually is a
problem if you were to run your web pack
build and play pay close attention to
the output this will basically tell you
a lot about what's happening when you
build web pack and you'll see every
individual module in that packs
directory get output or pre compiled
into the public directory and web pack
will say its emitted it's created a file
for each one of those that should be
served that's probably not what you want
so really this is just a quick fix just
keep in mind this convention only put
JavaScript files that you want to be
bundled as entry points in that package
directory and really you should see only
a limited number of files in that output
so survival tip number one really the
main point here is don't assume just
because things work a certain way in
sprockets and the rails asset pipeline
that they'll work the same way in web
pack and web Packer
all right another issue that came up was
like we wanted to do something like how
do you require tree in web path so we
get this really nice directive in
sprockets where we can include all the
files in some directory automatically
with this one line so this actually
doesn't work by default if you were to
import some directory in your es6 code
through web pack you'd actually have to
do a little bit of work to make this
functionally the same so a API that's
very specific to a web pack build is
called require context
and it lacks a little bit like directory
glob in Ruby you would use this to build
up a list of files within that directory
if you had an index directory
essentially an index file in essentially
aliases to that directory name and you'd
have to recurse and/or Susan the iterate
over these files and require them one by
one what if you wanted to actually grab
a component from that directory well you
have to do a little more work you'd have
to use the require context which builds
up again that glob of files you'd grab
the mod you build up a list of modules
you'd have to give them some name by
default maybe it's based off the file
name then you export that out from the
index file so that's available to other
modules in your system
okay so it's alright if you didn't get
all that but the main point here is that
you can do a lot of the things that you
get in sprockets but you have to give up
a little more of that friendliness that
we are used to maybe a more on the Ruby
side webpack tends to give you a lot of
flexibility in control and maybe the
api's aren't quite as nice as we'd like
them just something to keep in mind it
can be easy to get frustrated when
you're playing with these more low level
concepts
okay so moving on to taming dependencies
and one strategy we used in our rails
asset pipeline that we wanted to bring
over to webpack somebody called code
splitting so this is a simplified
version of how our sprockets build
looked a year ago so we had an
application Jas and a vendor Jas that we
included on the page at the same time
really the strategy here is to improve
our long-term caching we would put the
big libraries like jQuery and lodash
into our vendor Jas module or bundle and
the rest of our source code was an
application Jas and that might include
some vendor libraries like some of these
jQuery plugins and I'm gonna highlight
those two because we ran into a problem
when we moved this concept of manual
code splitting over to web pack so you
can imagine we tried to create an
application and a vendor Jas pack on our
web Packer side and instead of include
tags we have pack tags now and we
started moving jQuery over with an
import from our node modules and we
could actually do the same with these
jQuery plugins as well and we were
adding these to our our bundles and we
noticed that there was a problem I would
like to point out though that one thing
that we had to do to get this all to
work and this is specific to our needs
is that we told web pack which doesn't
put anything in the global scope by
default is that we need jQuery to be
available there because remember that we
have a lot of this code in our Ruby
templates that assumes jQuery is
available in the global scope that's how
things worked and sprockets and we can
actually tell web pack do this just for
jQuery you put it in the global scope
turns out that that had some serious
consequences for what we saw
okay so we're gonna step through the
process of moving these dependencies
over to webpack so we added jQuery and
it becomes available in the global scope
because of our configuration and then we
added this chosen j/s plugin it turns
out this is a fairly mature plugin it
hasn't been updated in a few years you
might be able to see where this is going
we could test to see that it worked on
the dev tools in the browser the chosen
function was added to the jQuery object
that's available globally and then we
pulled in slick carousel to another
jQuery plug-in it's actually fairly
active it's more I would say up-to-date
and we could see that that worked once
we imported it into our application
bundle but then something happened that
that shook me to my core
all of the sudden chosen was no longer
defined and the functionality that we
intended to provide was broken I had no
idea when I saw this how trying to do
the same thing in web pack that I'd done
in sprockets were just not work
turns out that there's a great tool that
you can add to your development
environments to help you see what's
going on inside your web pack build if
you already use webpack I really
encourage you to use the web pack bundle
analyzer web Packer gives you some
configuration that makes it a bit easier
to add in web pack configuration so you
can add this plug-in with some code that
might look like this in your development
configuration and what web pack bundle
analyzer will do is give you a
visualization of the relative size and
contents of all the modules that you
have and all the bundles that you're
you're building and you can actually
click around and zoom in and get some
stats and so this is what our bundles
look like after we had added these
plugins and jQuery you might be able to
see a small problem it's actually a
pretty big problem on the right is our
vendor bundle where we explicitly
imported jQuery and happily I can see
that it was imported and included in
that bundle what I was not so happy
about was that jQuery is also included
in our application bundle that's not
what I wanted
so this is actually a big problem
especially when we were doing what we
did which was trying to put jQuery into
the global scope well guess what the
last version wins because there can only
be one jQuery in the global scope that
meant any plugins we had added at some
point got clobbered we could prove this
by looking at the source code of these
plugins so chosen Jas actually looks
like this I took away most of the
functionality but there's this one key
line it assumes J queries in the global
scope so when we included it it worked
because that's how we configured our web
pack jQuery important with slick hair
cell is very different it uses a more I
would say modern pattern it doesn't
assume by default that jQuery is in the
global scope it has a snippet of code at
the top of its library definition that
looks like this this is typically called
the universal module definition actually
tests for the presence of some common
module loaders like common Jas and AMD
and turns out that webpack understands
these snippets here and so when it gets
to this line it says oh so the carousel
looks like you require jQuery I'm in the
application bundle right now and no one
else is required jQuery so I'm going to
go ahead and add it as a dependency and
that's why we were getting two versions
what we needed to do is tell web pack
where we want to include both of these
bundles on the same page so you need to
treat some of these common imports as
one
so rather than manual code split like we
had been doing we needed to let web pack
do the work now there are a number of
ways that you could approach this and it
turns out unfortunately this code that
I'm showing you here won't work in web
pack for of course so we're using web
pack 3 it's maybe important to get the
main concept which is that this plugin
that we've added it's called the Commons
chunk plug-in will extract all common
modules into the vendor bundle so if we
require jQuery in both it's only going
to end up in vendor
just keep in mind we won't be able to do
this in webpack form so we could see
that this worked when we looked back at
this bundle analyzer and we could see
that jQuery is now included the vendor
bundles on the left and our application
bundles actually gotten a loaded smaller
because these common modules have all
moved in to the applicator bundle from
application and there's only one
instance of jQuery now and our plugins
started working again this all brings me
to my third survival tip you really need
to know your dependencies in web pack
because they might be bringing in
dependencies that effects some
assumptions that you've made in your
configuration
all right another issue that has come up
that we've sort of alluded to indirectly
I call module shimming this is basically
applying transformations to your
dependencies we do this in sprockets
already we have things called pre
processors that change say our
CoffeeScript or our es6 code into normal
JavaScript and it turns out there are a
lot of pre processors and webpack that
are much more powerful I would say than
what we typically have in sprockets it
turns out they're not called
preprocessors though they're called
loaders and I have alluded to this
before already but we were putting
jQuery into the global scope using
something called an exposed loader which
says expose something to the global
scope again we're looking at now some
web Packer configuration and we can add
in a loader that's targeted only to
jQuery dependencies
and we can say hey jQuery when you're
imported it exposed the dollar variable
to the global scope and as you could
have seen already that caused some
problems and we found a better way to
address this issue while it did get our
chosen j/s plug-in to work because it
could find that jQuery dependency in the
global scope we could actually flip the
problem around and address it from the
other way instead of exposing jQuery to
the global scope
we ultimately decided to change how
chosen j/s works so we can use something
called the imports loader to actually
import the dependencies that it needs
where it otherwise expected them to be
available in the global scope this is
sort of like applying the universal
module definition to an old dependency
and here again is some web Packer
configuration which says every time we
try to import chosen j s apply the
imports loader and replace the jQuery
and the dollar reference with an actual
import to jQuery instead
that way we can inject the dependencies
rather than assume that they're
available in the global scope that way
we could start moving away from that
typical sprockets way of looking for
things globally
so survival tip number four if you have
legacy dependencies I highly recommend
you fix them through these loaders to
get them to work with webpack or just
get rid of them altogether if you have
the time webpack really wants to force
you into a certain way of doing things
all right finally predictable caching
let's talk about fingerprints so when we
ran our build and we have these two
bundles just like we have in the rails
asset pipeline we get fingerprints added
to the file names so for those who are
unfamiliar this Brett presents a digest
of the contents of these bundles and
what we want is for those digests to
stay consistent if the contents don't
change so we can cache them for long
term and if the contents do change we
want that digest to update so let's just
imagine in our application pack we're
doing something with our sum function
we're importing and let's add a new
dependency and that dependency might
actually just be very simple it doesn't
bring in new dependencies it's just a
plain module and we ran that build again
we could actually take a look and see if
the fingerprints change the way we would
expect now if I only change the
application bundle I would expect that
only the application fingerprint should
change you might be able to see where
this is going
so this is before and this is after the
change this is the fingerprint for the
application bundle before and after the
change and you can see that they are
different and unfortunately if you look
closely at the fingerprints of the
vendor bundles before and after the
change they are also different and at
this point I wanted to throw my computer
out the window I really had to search
deep inside my soul to figure out what
was happening I must have had some real
misunderstanding about how web pack
works like how could it be that caching
is just broken it turns out it actually
kind of is and to illustrate why I had
to learn how web pack works and I'm
going to illustrate now
let's imagine when you build your web
pack bundle it's going to start at the
entry file it's a JavaScript file and
what web pack will do is parse that file
for all your import statements and pull
in the dependencies that they refer to
and recursively it will go through each
of those dependencies parse those files
and pull in the dependencies of them so
what you get is a directed graph of
dependencies when you build web pack and
web pack will link all of these
dependencies together it will translate
these imports into function calls in the
browser that the browser can understand
when these modules that are then put
into your bundle it also will web pack
will insert some code which I'll call
the runtime that will make this all work
the runtime needs to keep track of these
modules somehow it will actually assign
each module an ID which you can think of
as indexes into an array literally that
first entry file gets the ID 0 and so on
and so forth well as you've seen early
or earlier we were actually using two
bundles vendor and application Jas and
because we were pulling common modules
into vendor Jas that meant the runtime
also ended up in vendor Jas and when we
make some kind of change to application
Jas those IDs would have to change as
well we might insert a module it needs
to get an ID itself other IDs might
become might change as a result and it
turns out because the runtime keeps
track of all those IDs like a manifest
file any change that we made to the
application bundle would cause the
runtime to change and since the runtime
is in the vendor bundle the vendor
bundle would change as well which is why
those fingerprints are updated well it
turns out there's a quick fix to this
more configuration so if you recall this
is what our common module configuration
looks like and it turns out what we
wanted to do our one way to fix this is
to pull that runtime out of the vendor
bundle so we had to yet add yet another
instance of this common chunks plugin to
pull the runtime out and we also added
some other plugin here it's called the
hashed module IDs plugin so that would
basically does is says don't don't
assign numeric IDs actually have the IDs
of each module represent the contents so
they won't change if we ship things
around so the end result of that change
meant the runtime was pulled into a
separate bundle so if we changed
application jas runtime would change as
well but bender would stay the same and
I was a compromise that we were willing
to make to at least get vendor caching
to be I guess stronger
okay so survival tip number five you may
need to understand a bit about how this
runtime works this is something this is
a completely new concept that we don't
get in the rails asset pipeline and if
you're looking all this and you're
starting to wonder oh dear God why would
I ever want to learn about all this
stuff I'd have to say that I want to
leave you with on a positive note here
so I want to come to one last issue that
actually I feel was a real big win for
bringing webpack into your project
called asynchronous bundles so let's
imagine some code that looks something
like this where you're using a pretty
large package to do something only some
of the time so for example at
learnzillion we use PDF j/s to render
PDF documents into canvas elements but
we really only need this on one
particular page of the site and it
wouldn't really make sense to put this
in our vendor bundle and force users to
download this requirement this package
on every single page load
so what we can do is take this code
which would end up which would place PDF
jeaious and the vendor bundle with our
configuration and make this one use this
one little trick here
so changing that import from statement
to an import function call there's
actually very different behavior from
web packs per second perspective so to
read this what we're saying is only when
this code is evaluated in the browser
well web pack make a request for this
package which is not in your vendor
bundle anymore
when web pack runs its build it will
actually separate this package out into
its own bundle that it can then request
on demand when this function call it
actually returns a promise which won't
resolve until that package is downloaded
only when it's this line is evaluated
and then we can then continue with
whatever was trying to do in this case
render a PDF really this is web packs
the sweet spot in fact it's the reason
why the creator of web pack wrote it was
to get this asynchronous on-demand
loading one little tip if you're going
to use this type of import
you have to use a magic comment in the
function definite or the function call
here to ensure that this chunk or which
chunk be meaning bundle in webpack terms
is actually gets a consistent name again
webpack doesn't always assume what you
want to do so you have to tell it in
this case I want to call it a certain
name and when you run this build you can
see now we actually have a fourth bundle
that's only used some of the time and
we're able to limit the size of these
initial bundles that are included on the
page load survival tip 6 if you're going
to use webpack i really encourage you to
prioritize using these asynchronous
bundles otherwise why to go to all the
trouble of setting it up if you're not
going to use what web pack was really
designed to do all right so we've
covered all the issues that I felt were
relevant to share today and although you
may not run into the same issues that we
ran into I really hope that you can see
the bigger picture here about how some
of the mindset we had coming from
sprockets really needed to be adjusted
when we came to web pack that said I
have to agree with the author of this
blog post that rails with web pack isn't
for everyone don't switch just because
you heard that it's cool okay I would
encourage you to really consider the
trade-offs if you have an application
that has a lot of JavaScript if you want
to take advantage of these new tools
that you want to use things like
asynchronous bundle loading yeah maybe
it's the right choice for you you'll
still probably have to invest some time
to learn how it works for other folks
may be something like sprockets for is
good enough
and web Packer really needs more support
and attention like DHH referenced in his
opening keynote it's a leaky abstraction
even though it hides from you a lot of
the complexity that you might get
otherwise if you had to setup web pack
yourself ultimately when I used it at
least I still needed to understand how
it all worked anyways but you know what
that's actually a good thing I feel like
it's the start of something that can
improve over time just keep in mind you
will have to stay up to date because
this project moves very fast because web
pack itself is changing constantly
so survival tip my final one understand
that webpack and sprockets are
fundamentally different they are set up
in very different ways they have
different strategies for bundling your
JavaScript code together they have very
different philosophies about what is
considered best practice as we saw web
pack really doesn't try to solve caching
for you that's something that it's left
up to you it tries to push you towards
smaller bundles not big ones it wants
you not to use global code but and maybe
even not jQuery at all and these are
things that you may need to reconsider
if you're going to make this switch but
most of all I will probably be
frustrating if this is your first time
using webpack keep a positive attitude I
know that this can be frustrating at
times as I've experienced myself if you
remember these tips that I've shared
with you maybe if they didn't sync and
fully come back to them later and I
promise you will survive your web pack
journey the slides for this talk will be
up on my website rostov at net slash
talks and I really like answering
questions about web pack or other Ruby
and rails types of topics reach out to
me my email address on rasta on twitter
and github and thank you all for coming
to rails cough thank you for coming to
my talk get home safe after tender loves
talk tonight and hope to talk to you all
soon thank you
[Applause]